- Right. Good afternoon folks.
You're here hopefully to learn about
how AMD Epic CPUs can help
you across a broad set
of general compute workloads
as well as AI workloads.
Quick bookkeeping.
I'll talk really loudly
until you wear your headset.
You're gonna have...
You're gonna need your headset to hear me.
Quick intro. I'm Madhu Rangarajan,
I run the server product team at AMD,
so all of the epic CPUs, product planning,
product management, and product marketing.
And I'll let Mike and Kyle
introduce themselves as well.
- Hey everyone. Mike Thompson here.
I am responsible for AMD's
public cloud products out in the world
across all the hyperscalers
based in North America
and soon to be Neo clouds.
- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Kyle McLaughlin.
I lead our FinOps practice at CVS Health
and talk more later.
- Okay, cool. Thanks everyone for coming.
I'll see you in a sec. All right.
- So I'm gonna cover the
first part and then Mike
and Kyle are gonna get into
progressively more detail.
If you look at AMD as a company
and how we've evolved, right?
We are looking at everything
as end-to-end solutions
because we understand our customers
aren't just looking
for a piece of silicon.
We've got CPUs, we got
GPUs, we got networking,
but more importantly, there
needs to be a software layer
that ties it all together.
And then there are solutions
and cluster level designs that
now we have the ability to do
through our acquisition of ZT systems.
So we are really looking at at ourselves
as an end-to-end solutions provider.
I'll be diving a little more
into the CPU today. Yeah.
Now jumping into the CPU,
if you look at the spectrum
of workloads, right?
You got general compute
and small AI workloads
and AI pipeline workloads and
classical machine learning
and things like that
that have been traditionally
done in the CPU
and continue to be done on the CPU.
If you go all the way to the right,
you got the AMD instinct GPUs.
So if you're doing any AI
at scale, LLMs at scale,
you're looking for real time inference,
really large generative
AI models and so on.
The instinct GPUs work
really well for that.
And of course the CPU continues
to be relevant throughout this
because AI doesn't live in a vacuum.
AI is a pipeline that
includes data input, cleaning,
pre-processing model
training, and then deployment.
So there's always this
system level interplay
between the CPU and the
GPU and the the networking
and clusters of all of these.
Okay.
Now jumping into inference a bit,
if you look at what's been happening
just over the last two
years, in 18 months,
the cost of inference
has gone down 280x, okay?
It was $20 per million tokens in 2022,
and it's $0.07 in 2024.
So this is like a new
version of Moore's Law
where the cost per token is
going down exponentially.
And what that means is if,
for those of you familiar
with Jevons Paradox, Jevons Paradox says,
when any resource becomes
low enough intern cost,
there is a significantly higher
consumption of that resource.
And that's exactly what
we are saying with all
of the insatiable desire for AI
and all of the silicon
growth that's happening.
And what does that mean?
The growth of inference.
As most of the big labs
and all of the companies
were doing training,
it was a little less "complicated,"
where the CPO did some data preparation
and then you had clusters of
GPUs doing all of the training
and there wasn't as much interplay,
although the CP was involved in it.
But as you transition to a world
where there's a lot more
inference happening than training,
it's a much more complex workload.
Now you've got a lot of pre-processing,
you've got things like rag pipelines,
and then you do the inference itself
and then you have to do post-processing
and there's an interplay
where there can sometimes be
iterative loops going back
and forth between the CPU and the GPU,
between general purpose
tasks and these more AI
or inference focused tasks.
And agent AI takes that
to an entirely different level, right?
Previously you just had a bunch
of users accessing a bunch
of compute of different kinds,
whether it's GPUs or GPUs or networking.
As agentic AI grows,
what you have is a bunch of users
deploying a whole bunch of agents
and these agents never sleep.
These agents are accessing
compute resources thousands
of times more than human beings.
And they're accessing all of
these web servers, databases,
media, CDNs, then they're
running all of the...
They're accessing AI accelerators.
So this is what's driving
that insatiable desire for compute.
You're looking at all of these
giant data center buildouts,
you're hearing about all of
the constraints on power.
You're seeing all of these
huge data center buildouts
that are happening.
It's happening exactly because of this.
And we don't see any signs of this abating
because as these agents
get more and more useful,
you're gonna see more and
more people deploy this.
Now getting further onto Epic
CPU side of things in general,
if you look at the Epic CPUs
and what we've been
delivering consistently
for a few generations now,
extremely high performance
across a broad set of workloads,
very power efficient,
one of the most efficient CPUs out there,
and TCO, total cost of ownership,
which we deliver through a
combination of performance
and core count as well as efficiency.
And if you look at the evolution
of the AMD Epic CPU roadmap,
we started with the Zen
one servers in 2017.
And when the Zen one
servers came out in 2017,
we probably had low
single digit percentage
in terms of market share.
Now going all the way to
the Zen five servers on SP5,
the product we call Turin, we
are now at 41% market share
and Zen six or Venice is
coming very soon next year.
And we expect the trajectory of growth
and market share growth at that AMD has
to continue for a while.
Now, this is a quick snapshot
of our fifth generation Epic or Turin,
which we launched late last year.
At the time of its launch,
we again delivered significant performance
over competition, right?
If you look at all of these metrics,
whether it's just
benchmarks like spec CPU,
or you're looking at a broad
set of enterprise workloads
or HPC workloads like two, three,
and 4x more performance than
anything competition has
to offer even on CPU based AI workloads,
just a core count and the memory bandwidth
and everything else we had
to offer gives you up to 3.8x
on various AI workloads.
And now, even if you are using a GPU,
it is actually extremely
important to pick the right CPU.
So we created a part
called the Epic 9575F,
which a high frequency processor,
and the main job of the processor
is to get out of the way
of the GPU so that the
GPU can process things
and not bottleneck the GPU.
And what that translates
into is on a GPU server,
20% more performance out of the GPU just
by minimizing the time spent waiting
for the CPU to do stuff.
If you look at that in the
context of, I dunno, 300,
$400,000 GPU server, that's
tens of thousands of dollars
of performance per dollar
that it translates into.
So whether you're running
your workloads on a CPU
or a GPU,
the CPU is kind of ubiquitous there
and it's extremely important to make sure
that you pick the right
CPU to run those workloads.
And again, if you're running
AI inference itself on the CPU,
and Mike will get into maybe
more details on this broad set
of AI inference workloads
run really well on Epic.
For example, if you look
at machine learning,
decision tree, sub flow support
vector machines and so on,
those workloads run use high
precision vector engines.
They do really well on the CPU.
When you have LLMs and generative AI,
especially if you have a small
and smaller language models,
small scale deployments
where you have, for example,
a chat bot that's not busy all the time.
The CPU actually does really well
in the large memory capacity
that a CPU has to offer,
is very helpful there.
And then just recommendation
systems as well as AI apps
where you have a mix
of like general compute
with AI embedded in that overall pipeline.
CPUs tend to be really
good at those workloads.
And of course that's the hardware piece
and it's extremely important
for our customers to be able
to consume this easily
in terms of software.
So what we are, AMD is
extremely focused on making sure
the open source ecosystem is enabled.
So if you look at how we are
gonna make sure you are able
to consume the performance easily,
we are enabling the standard
frameworks, PyTorch,
TensorFlow and Onyx.
Now, all of these will
work right out of the box,
and in general, they
actually do pretty well.
Now, if you wanna kick your
performance up a notch,
we got this plugin called ZenDNN,
they plug into these
frameworks pretty seamlessly
and you can get more
performance out of it.
It's not required,
but it can help tune
your performance further.
And we are actually working
through upstreaming a lot
of those optimization directly
into those frameworks.
So you at some point you don't
even have to use a plugin.
And again, just to sum it up
before I hand over to Mike,
why use Epic CPUs for AI workloads?
The first is accessibility.
CPUs are omnipresent.
You can find it across
regions, across data center,
across clouds, whether you're on-prem
or in the cloud, it's ubiquitous.
And you got this standard
X86 software stack
that you can leverage across
and without any porting you can get.
You can run your workload.
Utilization opportunities.
A lot of customers have servers in either
in their data centers where
they're sitting at 20,
30% utilization
or they've bought a whole
bunch of reserved instances.
And those reserved instances
are sitting idle a lot.
So you can actually do batch processing
of AI workloads on the downtimes
and increase your utilization
and make more effective use
of the hardware that you've already got.
Third one is scalability,
especially when you're in the cloud.
You can have a baseline amount of capacity
and you can scale your
capacity up and down.
That's the value prop of cloud.
That's why all of you're here.
And the last one of course is
if you want operational simplicity
where your AI workloads are
a little more small scale
and you want to have a
relatively uniform fleet
without having to manage
multiple types of infrastructure
and figure out how many of each type
of infrastructure you
wanna deploy and so on.
With the CPU, you get a unified platform,
you can get a single
type of cloud instance
to support a broad set of workloads.
And with that, I'm
gonna hand over to Mike,
who's gonna kind of get you go
get you through more details.
- Awesome, thank you Madhu. Hey everyone.
Mike here again, I manage
AMD's global cloud product,
and I'm here to talk
to you today about some
of the cost efficiencies
that you can extract
by just making the simple choice
of selecting your processor,
your compute platform wisely.
And I'll also go into some
details about when does it
actually make sense to
do inference on CPU.
A lot of people think AI is GPU,
and to some extent that is true,
but there's, we've been
doing AI on CPU since 1950,
so 75 years.
And especially as you know,
we finish up this huge era
of training, or at least
we've done enough training
to be able to start
actualizing those models,
making them available to the broad public.
You should really consider
carefully where you deploy those.
There's some pretty significant benefits
that you can get from an
availability and cost perspective.
Now, to take a step back,
choosing your compute platform
really does matter.
Historically, a lot of
folks have thought about
their compute platforms,
the CPUs that they're renting
in the cloud as a commodity
and may overlook some of the benefits
that you can get from performance.
A little bit later today we'll
have Kyle from CVS on stage
and he'll talk a little bit about
how they were able to get an OPEX return
by choosing the compute platforms wisely.
This is an example,
AMD Epic CPUs are have a really,
really good architecture.
They have really good
implementations in AWS
that enable them to have
incredible performance up
to 2X performance.
And that comparison is comparing Ice Lake
or a 6I to a Genoa or a 6A.
So one generation difference,
you can get a 2X performance uplift.
If you're just choosing
your compute platforms
by whatever's ever been done before,
you could be leaving an
awful lot of your OPEX
or your TCO on the table.
So with that 2X performance,
you can drive almost 50% lower cost
for the jobs that you're running.
The jobs that are most suited for that
are ephemeral jobs or containerized jobs
or batch jobs
where you spin up the servers
when they're ready to be used
and then you spin them down
when they're done through.
That mechanism,
what we call performance
driven cost optimization.
Literally with four clicks of
your mouse in the AWS console,
stop your instance, hit the
instance select or drop down,
select an instance with
an A in it for AMD,
you'll see the little lowercase A for EC2
and start your instance again.
You can drive your your
burn rate, 45 down 45%.
And so that's the impact
of performance driven optimizations.
And then do we have anyone
here from Europe today?
Anyone from AMEA? Couple?
Okay, so what I've observed is the concern
with energy consumption in
Europe is pretty significant.
There's some existential challenges there.
And so I see a lot
of the decisions about deploying
infrastructure in Europe.
One of the primary concerns is
actually energy consumption.
And so by the same token,
by choosing a MD powered instances,
whether you're doing them on-prem
or in the cloud,
you get up to 2.2 x better
performance per watt.
So every watt you burn,
you get more than double
the work out of it.
Sometimes those numbers
can be a little bit hard
to tease out of the hyperscalers,
but you get both of those benefits,
you get performance
and hence a lower cost,
but you also consume a lot
less energy while you're at it.
If anyone is interested in diving
into more details about that,
please stop by afterwards.
We'll be out here to
chat for a little while
or swing by the AMD
booth on the show floor.
All right, so A MD CPUs can really help
address a couple of the key AI challenges.
One, when most customers
or most organizations,
they set their budgets at
the beginning of the year,
whether it's calendar year or fiscal year.
You get your budget,
you allocate it to whatever
applications or business units
and then you go and execute.
Well, there's so much innovation
in AI happening right now
that you can't anticipate
what you're gonna need in August
when you set your budget in January.
And so one of the ways that
we've seen customers take advantage
of these performance driven
cost optimizations is
to go into their maybe just
their general IT infrastructure,
do that four click
transformation to drive roughly,
we see 27 to 45% cost savings
that can come from just simply switching
to AMD powered instances.
They free up that budget
and they can take that
and either invest it in.
A lot of times it's innovation.
So AI applications or advanced analytics,
but also for business growth.
You know, if customers
are having, you know,
significant amount of business growth,
they need more capital to
deploy, more infrastructure,
to drive more revenue as
you're growing, right?
And so that's kind of a secret way
that you can unlock
budget that you might not
otherwise think you have.
Those efficiencies in the infrastructure
they already have deployed.
So higher performance
means faster runtime,
smaller footprint, or
smaller instance size.
All of those can drive lower OPEX,
especially for instance size.
Like for instance, if
you get 2X performance
and you're running SQL server,
which is licensed per core,
and those software, those
license software applications,
that license cost tends
to dominate your TCO,
it's usually 80 to 90, often 80 to 90%
of your TCO is wrapped up
in those license costs.
And so if you take advantage
of that 2X performance,
that means you can cut
your instant size in half,
that means your number of cores
or VCPUs goes down by half
and that's what your software
is often licensed on.
So you can dramatically
drive down your TCO
including the licensing cost.
And in that case, the infrastructure
is a small portion of it.
You roughly can expect
about a 45% TCO return
when you're doing that
based on SQL server packaged
with the instance from AWS 45% cost return
for those software applications.
And then finally, since
we're mostly here today
to talk about inference or AI,
Inference on CPU is very cost effective.
I'll show you some ways
that that is enabled today.
CPU instances are highly available.
They tend to be more broadly
geographically available
than GPU instances.
There tends to be more pool depth,
they're highly portable as well.
Let's say your AI workload shuts down,
you can put any general
purpose workload on a CPU,
can't always do that with
GPUs, don't get me wrong.
GPUs are great, also very
important, we need those,
but CPUs tend to be more portable
and you can also repurpose those instances
for other applications.
You know, one of the
things, talking with dozens
and dozens of customers,
one of the challenges
that customers face in terms
of getting the most out
of their investment in infrastructure,
and this is honestly on-prem and cloud,
but here what we're looking at is
what is the typical CPU utilization
over the course of 24 hours?
You'll notice from midnight
till early in the morning,
a lot of the compute
isn't getting used at all.
And then it peaks when
everyone comes to work,
then it drops off around dinner time,
then after dinner time you
can see another little peak
and then it drops off again.
So that's kind of
dramatically underutilized
compute resource,
especially if you've paid
for like a long term
fixed price contracts,
you're literally burning
money doing nothing.
And so one of the things that
you can do for AI applications
that aren't necessarily real time,
there's a lot of analytics
associated with it.
Maybe like let's say you
run a streaming service
and you want to come up with
new movie titles to recommend
to your users tomorrow.
Well, you can insert those AI workloads
during these non-peak hours.
If you're doing inference
that is not latency sensitive,
that's really, really well suited to CPU
and it enables you to get
more out of your investments.
So you can deliver
insight during off hours.
You can maximize the value
of your reserved instance
fixed price contracts.
And I'll show you a little
bit more in a moment.
You can leverage the really,
really good performance
of AMD Epic CPUs.
Again, look for the A
in the instance name to run
these inference applications.
Now, here are some examples
of why you might want
to do inference on CPU.
First, I'm showing one
of the leading GPU instances
for doing inference
versus an M7A instances.
This is from our Genoa Epic processor,
7A, M7A versus G6E.
You can see that the CPU instance in blue
is about one third the
cost of the GPU instance.
Consider with that utilization
curve we just looked at,
why would you wanna work
burn three times the rate
when you're only using about half of it?
So there's many applications for inference
where using CPUs makes a lot of sense.
If you're not latency sensitive,
it makes a lot of sense if you
have small and medium models,
it makes a lot of sense.
Has anybody in the audience had like
a meeting summary agent join
any of your calls afterwards?
Five minutes after your meeting ends,
it sends you a summary.
What about, has anyone had,
what do they call that,
the transcript where it just
does the voice recognition
and sends you the transcript?
Does anybody read the
transcripts in full? Nobody does.
Does anybody read the summary? I do.
I read the transcripts once about a year
and a half ago I think,
and then when the summary
agents came around.
So now those summary agents,
do you really care whether
that summary turns up in
your inbox immediately
as you exit the meeting?
Or if it shows up five
minutes later, is that fine?
It's fine, right?
And so that's an example of a case
where CPU inference makes a lot of sense.
You do it at a 66% discount,
it's much more highly available
and more geographically distributed.
So that's one of the
reasons you might consider
inference on CPU.
And so now I'm gonna
start diving into some
of the technical details.
We've run loads and loads of benchmarks
for inference workloads.
I'm just selecting one of them here.
Here we're looking at a model
that does natural language
processing, like something that,
a model that can deliver
customer service agent,
customer service agents,
or interact with you to
understand, you know,
understand the language
that you're asking.
It's a way to interact with
humans to process language.
Just making a simple choice
in your compute platform can
have a dramatic impact on your cost.
And here we're looking
at an M7I versus an M7A
and because of the performance uplift,
if you look at the instant
sizes under the chart here,
you'll see the gray.
When you move from gray to blue,
you cut the instant size in half.
We either go from 4XL
to 2XL or 8XL to 4XL.
If you speak instant
sizes in terms of EC2.
That higher performance on the M7A
AMD epic powered instances enables you
to achieve similar performance
at roughly 40% lower cost.
You know, right now we're going
through a fairly decent economic cycle,
but the next time an
economic downturn comes,
that 40% difference in
your burn rate can make
a tremendous difference in frankly,
the number of people that
you can keep employed, right?
So it also can free up a lot of capital
to invest in other
applications, new applications,
business growth and so forth.
So that's the impact
that performance can
have on your applications
with a very just simple
conscious selection
of an optimal platform
for your applications.
All right, and so now looking
at when does it make sense
to do inference on CPU?
So on the left here, we're listing a range
of applications from
classical NML, which you know,
technically don't really use models
to recommendation systems.
That's what your Netflix movie
recommendations come from.
Natural language processing, we probably,
we interact with that all the time.
Gen AI for large language models
as well as mixed workloads.
A lot of applications now have
a mix of traditional software
and AI driven software.
So for the model size,
generally you're gonna see
CPU inference works well for small
and medium sized models except
for classical ML and MLP
and NLP, Natural Language Processing.
CPU can handle all the model sizes
and then offline versus
real time offline is a way
to express not latency
sensitive or not real time.
So generally, if you're
not latency sensitive
or not running real time,
CPU makes sense in all of these cases.
In a few of the cases you want GPUs
and AMD has great GPUs as
well though today we're here
to mostly talk about
CPUs, but for classical ML
and recommendation systems,
you can even run those on CPU.
There are some large
streaming services today
that are doing just that,
that I would imagine almost
everyone in the audience here
experiences every time they go
to use their favorite streaming service.
And so Net-Net, why use
AMD CPU powered instances
for inference?
It really boils down to performance,
which drives cost savings for you
and can drive much better user experience
for your end users.
You get over double the price performance,
meaning performance per dollar
or whatever currency you
happen to be operating in
just by choosing instances with
the lowercase a in the name.
And that is what enables you
to drive on average across a wide range
of inference workloads, 44% lower OPEX.
And so the the fundamental
concept there is consider
the platform that you're
deploying your applications on.
If you just deploy it
wherever you have before
you're probably spending
more than you need to.
This is one of the main interest
that we see broadly from
our customers today.
And up next we're gonna have
Kyle McLaughlin from CVS Health
telling you a little bit about
how in CVS's FinOps practice,
they've taken advantage
of these kinds of performance
driven optimizations.
So Kyle.
- Thanks Mike.
Good afternoon everyone.
See if I can figure out, remember.
There we go. All right, cool.
So quickly, just a
little bit about myself.
I'm Kyle McLaughlin.
I lead the FinOps practice at CVS Health.
I've been there for about 18 months,
but been in the FinOps space
for about seven years now.
Previously worked at
the FinOps Foundation,
which sets the standards and
best practices for FinOps.
It's a project of the Linux Foundation.
Spent several years as
well at a number of FinOps.
So what was really exciting
for me about the opportunity
to come to CVS is I could take
a startup experience working
with different organizations
all over the world.
The industry best practices,
and go back to where I started my career,
get back to a big company and see
about how we do FinOps at scale.
Enough about me though.
Let's talk about CVS.
Most people know CVS
for the retail presence.
You see the stores on every corner.
What a lot of folks don't know
is CVS also owns Aetna Insurance.
We have a giant pharmacy division
and we also have a
healthcare delivery division.
Combine all that together in one package.
You have a US-based healthcare company
that has a full end-to-end solution about
how we can treat our members at every step
of their healthcare journey.
We're a Fortune five organization
and we're on pace for about
$400 billion in revenue this year.
Combine all that with us going
through a major tech transformation,
we are trying to modernize
and enhance our tech
stack while still serving
100 million customers a day.
So safe to say we have a
fairly significant cloud spend,
but at the end of the day,
for us to support our members,
stability is our overarching priority.
So where does FinOps
come into play for CVS?
Well, to manage all that spend,
make sure we're adding value
for our member experience.
It's really important that
we have good visibility
into tracking the application spend,
understand who those owners are.
And it's also not just about spend,
it's about what's the business value
that we're getting out of
that incremental dollar.
So we'll go back to Slide.
Who here was not familiar with FinOps
before they showed up at this talk
or has never heard of FinOps?
Love it my friend.
You're going to get baptized by fire here.
This is the FinOps framework.
I no longer work there,
so if you don't like it,
I'll tell you who you can take it up with.
But a lot of content
here work with me folks.
Being in the space for seven years,
I have found everything boils down to,
I'm gonna pick the smallest
graphic on the screen,
which is great for a presentation, inform,
optimize, operate.
We call this the phases of FinOps.
And really everything
that we're doing ties back
to these three phases.
It's impossible to go save
that money if we don't know
who's spending it in the first place.
So everything always boils
back to how's our visibility?
How are we doing in the informed phase?
From there we think about optimizing
and then once we've optimized,
there's frankly too much work to do
that we can't just keep sitting
there doing the same things.
We need to find ways to
operationalize that work,
automate it when possible,
and then we enter right
back into the wheel again.
And we talk about a lot of
work to do in the FinOps space.
We touch a lot of different personas.
Let's see if I make sure I got
the laser right. There we go.
A FinOps practice.
Executives care about it.
Our friends in cloud engineering,
we are heavily dependent
on them in a partnership
in order to have success.
Procurement's extremely interested,
finance is extremely interested.
You have to work with all
these different personas
across the organization.
And then the framework,
we have these ideas of
domains and capabilities.
A domain is really what you
should be doing in this case.
How do we quantify business value?
The capabilities are how
we go about doing that.
How we measure the business value
is concepts like unit economics.
It's fine if your cloud
spend goes up by 10%
as long as you're serving
20, 30% more customers.
And that's really how we
think about cloud spend
and the value that we're
generating out of it.
So I'll go back again,
there's a lot of content on this slide.
I really wanna talk through
what we've been doing at CVS,
what I think are our biggest priorities
and we're leading to some of
the successful results
that we've had so far.
So let's start with inform.
Again, everything comes back
to knowing who's the resource
owner who spun this thing up,
and then what are we gonna do about it?
We are able to map
all of our resource
owners through our CMDB.
This contains the technical
owner information, app owners,
all that good detail.
Not only do we need this
for security purposes,
but we're also able to charge
back all of our cloud costs
to those application owners.
So we put all this emphasis on our CMDB
to make sure we have the
proper visibility of who
that owner is and then
also hold 'em accountable
for the spend that they're generating.
We also believe in operating
with complete transparency
on your cloud spend.
I have engineering teams that
are interested in knowing
what they're spending in cloud.
We make sure they have
the appropriate visibility
through different tools
that we have internally.
Optimize, the fun stuff.
One of the biggest wins
we've had is really trying
to focus on standardizing our SKUs
that we have engineering
spinning up infrastructure.
By standardizing the SKUs,
that really allows us to
take advantage of the price
and performance reasons
and implement those Enos
best practices at time
of resource creation.
Then we can focus more of our
time on how do we chase down,
you know, resources that are created
before automation went into place.
Consolidate on SKUs gets back
to what Madhu talked about.
It allows us to really optimize
and max out the savings
that we're getting from reserved instances
and savings plans.
And we're able to manage all this
with a combination of tools.
some of the folks that you
might see out on the expo floor.
And we're fortunate enough to
have some engineering teams
that build custom solutions for us.
You know, when we can't
quite meet our needs
and we again,
give that total visibility
to teams internally.
So if people want to
go and see their costs,
they want to optimize,
they have tools available
to 'em to get that done.
But again, going back to the first slide,
we can't just keep doing the
same thing over and over again.
We're a relatively small team.
How do we operationalize this?
A couple places where we
found a lot of great results,
specifically partnering with
our largest application teams.
Generally it's just
like any 80/20 analysis,
80% of your spend is
probably gonna come from
about 20% of your total applications.
And what we found is by partnering closely
with these large application teams,
building the relationship,
investing the time,
getting to know what
they're trying to solve,
typically leads to great
results down the road.
We had one application team in particular
where we just approached
them about a fairly simple,
fairly straightforward SKU change.
Fast forward about nine
months, we now have
that engineering team refactoring
applications completely
re-architecting how they deploy
and even finding really nuanced
optimization opportunities
that are far outside the
skill set of our FinOps team.
But because we built that
relationship with them,
frankly got 'em a little
hooked on the savings,
they've really leaned into it
and we've have a great partnership
and we've been able to replicate
that across other application teams.
We were talking earlier, CVSs,
we have 300,000 employees.
It's a large organization
and we're spread across
four major business units.
So we've also been working
to establish working relationships
with all the different bus and make sure
that we're evangelizing
and spreading these best practices
throughout the organization.
And then where possible automate.
So we have automated
communication channels,
making sure we're getting
the right information
to the right people at the right time.
We're constantly exploring new
ways to get that information
to our app owners and the people
who are passionate about managing
their cloud resources effectively.
And that's really been a key for
how we scale FinOps
program at the size of CVS.
So where are we going from here?
Containers continue to
be a growing presence
in our overall cloud portfolio.
It's gonna be a major focus
for us for the next few years.
Is same thing going through
the same three phases
of the FinOps lifecycle
and form, optimize, operate,
make sure we're getting
best in class visibility
and granularity of what's
going on within each
of those namespace and pods.
And then exploring different
optimization opportunities
about how we more
efficiently pack resources
and use the right VM for that workload.
We've done a good job so far
of implementing standards,
but we really need to start
transitioning to a place
of policy and governance
and for an organization of our scale,
it's also how do you
do real world mediation
with real exception management.
You know, it's easy for anyone to go
and say, we need to go do this one thing,
but a company as as large
and as complex as ours,
we need to be able to handle
different use cases as well.
And you're welcome.
I'm saving my last bullet point at the end
to say the word AI.
We are also looking at ways
to leverage the latest
technology for FinOps best.
And it's really two lens.
There's FinOps for AI,
everyone knows the spends growing there,
the tooling's still
relatively new in the market.
We need to get more granular
visibility into what's going on
with these AI workloads.
And then we can have the fun optimization
and operational conversation
at the same time.
AI can also be used to help
you generate your insights,
the introduction of chatbots and agents.
We can now be leveraging AI
to help us generate our
insights at the end of the month
as opposed to fully relying on dashboards
and analysts diving into the data.
So I'll be here after the talk
if anyone wants to talk more,
happy to answer any questions
and I'll pass it back over to Madhu.
Cool.
- Right. Thank you very much Kyle.
So just to wrap it all up,
tying it back to the
overall team of this, right?
How do you build an excellent platform
that can span a broad set
of workloads including AI inference,
epic CPUs provide that platform.
I think Mike walked you
through various examples.
And then again, the CPUs are
just the means to an end.
The instance is how you're consuming it.
And Mike of course walked
you through the EC2 instances
that can help you realize this TCO value.
And in terms of the ease
of use getting started
with an AMD epic powered
EC2 instance is really easy
regardless of what your starting point is,
your starting from an old Intel instance,
it just works, right?
I think for those of
you with long memories,
you might remember that
back in the day there was
this whole IA-64 versus
X86-64 instructions.
That debate
and AMD went down the path
of X86-64 while Intel
went down the IA-64 path
and the market spoke.
And X86-64 is what's arrived.
And that is why all the applications
just work in most cases.
And once you move over to an AMD instance,
most cases you're gonna
get more performance.
Most cases it just works
and then you can get even more performance
by doing further tuning.
So really I said, so the Epic
kind of gives you the ability
to essentially just lift
and shift and then optimize.
You don't have to do a whole
lot of porting work together.
With that, I wanna thank Kyle and Mike
and all of you for attending.
We will be available to answer questions.
We have about 20 minutes
and so we can hang around
and answer any questions you have.
Thank you very much.